[Music]
oh yes be sure to tune in to the laurel
coral debate stream
oh when's the date october the 22nd
who's going to be our special guest
donald trump jr
and what are the drinking game rules
well you'll have to tune in to find out
tune
in please
tune in to the crowder debate stream
thursday october 22nd with a costume
contest
drinking game and a very special guest
subject for today
[Applause]
i knew that if i put the jacket on you
would be confused put on a judge's robe
and a powdered wig like you're running a
court in canada it's a silly place
fine i will we actually do that in
canada
silly canada the fact that you are a
country canada
is proof that we are not the evil
emperor can you imagine the option for
the romans
if you were to just try and tell a greek
wait what are you
you're saying that they're right there
right there i mean there's
no defense whatsoever
good luck with your globe trotting all
right
we have a lot to do my half age and
larry bill richmond is here quarter
black garrett is here audio
she's so cute it makes me throw up in my
mouth little gerald a is here how are
you i am doing well sir how are you good
we have so much to get to today uh
i didn't i don't care so
today what we'll be talking about
christian walker the debate moderator
for tomorrow a lot of people are telling
you that she has a stellar reputation
she's uh
an objective journalist no uh it would
be wrong
and something i noticed that no one's
been talking about have you gone to joe
biden's website joe biden's website and
go to gun safety
his website maybe it's gun control
you'll see it on his website and his
policies
no one's talking about it he wants to
take your guns away
very clearly and not just some guns all
guns he wants to make it impossible
for you to purchase new firearms it is
the most radical platform i've ever seen
you know why they're not talking about
it
because if you know what he's about he
loses michigan in pennsylvania garen oh
yeah absolutely
you think people in deer hunting season
people who count down the days are going
to vote for the guy who wants to
ban all sales of firearms ammunition or
accessories
no of course not but you promise the
unions a few kickbacks you might get a
couple of votes good for him
yeah uh we're talking about that and
also my half-assing lawyer bill richmond
afterwards we want your chat lotto
credit.com send us your chat your legal
questions about section 230
we'll be talking about the antitrust
suit against google uh
and we're uh really happy to have them
half vision lawyer but first before we
get to any of that
um robert downey well chris pratt you
know committed the cardinal sin
of not endorsing a candidate oh yeah oh
not
even going didn't show up for a biden
fundraiser oh
so no i thought it was out there how
dare he yeah
i thought it was just being a successful
white male i think that's that's
a hangable offense well i didn't listen
two things can
can be true someone can commit multiple
crimes that's true well he's also a
christian so i think that's a problem
that's another one listen we don't want
to ruin his career forever
he probably wants to go to church don't
put him next to our lord
so he didn't show up for a biden
fundraiser and people started attacking
him
left and right all over social media and
robert downey jr defended him on
instagram i want to read you what he
wrote he wrote what a world the sinless
or casting stones that my brother chris
pratt a real christian who lives by
principle
has never demonstrated anything but
positivity and gratitude and he just
made it into a family that makes space
for civil discord and just plain fact
insists on service as the highest value
if you take issue with chris i've got a
novel idea
delete your social media accounts sit
with your own defects of character work
on them
and so of course this was actually
surprisingly
very level yeah that's great and uh the
left on twitter responded pretty much
exactly how you'd expect
it were
do you mean when she was cast in the
biggest flop of modern marvel history
well people insulted her because she was
a woman no i think people assaulted her
because they didn't really like some
reviews she was hired
because she was a woman uh she was
higher why didn't she hide well because
dance
that's why we're not even interacting we
need more female
superheroes said the executives
not the viewers uh so this is where we
are in this country it is
absolutely remarkable uh really quickly
do you think about supporting us going
to merch door light of cuttershop.com
we have ranger panties we have shirts we
have new hoodies do you not have the
deal there going on am i still in there
i feel like someone sent a
sent a picture of me with my little
kraken poster correctly
oh yeah i have no idea what happened um
and then of course do consider joining
my club it's the only thing that allows
us to continue tomorrow
huge debate stream we have both senator
ted cruz and
donald trump jr you got both yeah we got
both whoa whoa both of them to pre-game
pretty awesome so um every time donald
trump jr cusses we have to take a shot
oh no
the whole donation is just gonna be hey
hey
hey hey i don't like you
i love you guys hell i love you we're
going to sound like joe biden
yeah and my question don't say that
because you get banned from making fun
of the stutter he doesn't have
he doesn't have a stutter though i just
wish that when when he
when someone tried to promote that like
jake tapper yeah when he just said uh
well you know that he has a stutter joe
biden how did i just wish that you would
hear producer on the other side of the
call going
[ __ ] i don't think you'll hear it no
what
what was that what was your colleague
saying that you're full of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
more like jake [ __ ] okay this has
gone off the rails
are you going to masturbate oh no oh no
it's the cnn speaking which let's go to
cnn
really quickly oh there we go trump
abruptly ends 60 minutes interview
taunt leslie stall you know what i will
say this that's the first time i've seen
an accurate headline
did he taunt her yeah he did he posted
an image of her not wearing her mask
that's not taunting that's
showing the facts i don't think how's
that taunting i don't think that it
helps uh with anyone other than the bass
but count me in yeah i enjoy it you know
what the comeback from cnn was she was
talking to her producers
genocide that's true it's true uh
and let me ask this have you been aware
have you been aware of biden's
anti-gun policies just how radical they
are we're going to go through that here
some of this is news to me he's never
been asked are you aware that he wants
to ban
all online sales of guns parts
accessories ammunition immediately we'll
go into the actual writing from his
website have you heard the media report
on it at all
trick question of course they have not
it's not in the debate topics
uh but i think i know why and the acb
before we move on to kristin
walker is it welcome welcome welcome
welcome
welcome er welch's grape juice made from
concord grapes
so um are they this is going to be
confirmed they're not
just love that one yeah welch's like
don't freak out welch's will send us a
legal note
don't let the just the the the
don't let welch's welch's leave your
lips one more time stephen crowder or
i'll just
sue you i bet when i get back to my
office later
there's literally going to be a letter
there there'll probably be a courier
there yeah
and they will throw the jam at me
you know what ring it welches i still
think your juice is delicious
i don't care so before i move on to
everything else a lot of people may have
forgotten about this
amy coney barrett is very likely to be
confirmed
starting monday uh and a lot of people
maybe miss this she has record approval
and that was an interesting thing we
were talking about confirming acb it
changed my mind people are saying well
most americans don't want to that's why
an argument can't be based on just
popular opinion
it can be used as an undergirding form
of support
but it should not be the basis of your
argument because more americans support
her confirmation
and here is a highlight for uh anyone
who missed the best
from the acb hearings it is the third
day of hearings the second straight day
that judge barron is fielding questions
from
senators i hope you got some rest uh
last night so let's lay this out for
everyone who's watching what is
the scheme here is row a super precedent
how would you define super precedent i i
actually i might but here's the bradley
foundation
do you accept that smoking causes cancer
well
think about it and currently consider
the consequences
of your rulings on people's lives well
senator harris that's part of the
decision of every case
this is a to me i've never seen this do
you think it is appropriate
for justices to consider real world
impacts
in their decision making just a
simple question that i hope you'll feel
comfortable asking do you think it's
wrong to separate children from their
parents
i imagine you were surrounded by a team
of folks that helped prepare you for
this nomination
hearing i haven't had that yesterday
yeah but let me finish repeating
i'm sorry including the welford judge
barrett
yes i'm sorry too you know i don't think
you even mentioned arbitrary and
creationists
the federalist society remember this
group
i thought you initially framed the
question as whether i was aware before
this nomination process
began questions if you are aware were
you aware before this hearing began
we should be doing something else right
now and it goes on
you condemn white supremacy correct how
many bubbles
are in a bar of soap now people may say
what does all this matter
well as you know i i've stayed away
simply because
like it's not three schemes
sexual preference is an offensive
and outdated term this hearing is not
normal
it is a sham odiferous
emmy key who might be behind this uh my
uh
my concern uh
[Music]
it's not even a case let me you know
janice and it's really about a
completely different case
called abu it's not normal this is not
normal
nothing about this today is normal have
you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
coming in
little flotillas my
as quickly as practical as practicable
i'm not the only one who sees this as a
saga
based on that schedule they could at the
moment get this done before election day
yeah i think that's a safe bet was
hirono was she referencing the
cretaceous period
the late triassic arbiter and gracious
what did she i didn't hear what she said
i think she's trying to say capricious
she was trying to uh
very capricious she's only been in the
united she's only been stateside
uh since always um excuse me
uh listen this is one thing where on
youtube
they consider it a slur to be like oh
but just as far as kamala has let me
finish no you asked a question
and she was answering let me finish like
the the bitchiness knows no bounce and i
don't say that about everyone i really
don't yeah
whitmer sure uh uh uh nancy pelosi
yeah mama harris just acts like such a
[ __ ] and i would not say that about for
example like klobuchar i don't think i
just disagree with her right yeah i
don't i wouldn't use that insult towards
her i don't think that she is i hate
that pause
i'm not too cute maddie's gonna save me
oh globutar's definitely a [ __ ]
is that the only thing daddy has said
this is scary and i could hear it put
quotes on normally
it was like a low volume slowly she felt
an ember inside
and it started to grow that was your
moment she just went
out she went ralphy
klobuchar who goes ralphie i need a
shirt i need a shirt yeah
someone making that chair is a [ __ ]
briefcase for when i go to court yeah
pop it right on the table
try and van that one is hate speech she
can say it because she's a lady
speaking of ladies we need to go uh up
next to this
lady who will be moderating the debate
of course tomorrow right
we have our live stream starting
tomorrow starting a little early because
of two guests but uh
cr kristen walker right correct
is it welcome someone corrected me when
i said welker walker
swelker okay red welcome welcome maddie
look
for texas [ __ ] to use maddie's um
and here's the thing to discuss before
we get into it um
how do i and i'll give you some research
that might surprise you uh five things
you need to know about her
my thoughts are if you can't say it
better than the best
just just steal from them how do you
write women so well
i think of a man and i take away reason
and accountability okay
so christian welker has had long ties
not just to the democratic party not
just being a liberal but actually
going to social functions working with
having romantic relate like all kinds of
ties
right behind the scenes which we will
get into but what mostly matters of
course is for example
you could be i don't know maybe you
could be george stephanopoulos where you
were a white house communications
director under the clintons
but maybe he can be objective and so you
look to his behavior and then you flip
through the behavior you go
oh no oh no no no he's a shell yep
i wanted to give you the benefit of the
doubt and he wears lifts
oh who does that that's embarrassing
little people
little pickles i thought you were
talking about high heels so let's go
through a couple of examples i don't
know if you remember this where uh she
was asking
donald trump uh if he uh this was after
someone
uh had gone after him if he was rattled
so here is the actual exchange
just so you know this is important
because i've always talked about this
when donald trump has been able to
communicate with people directly when
he's doing those white house briefings
he does better
you look at these states the swing
states he's within the margin of error
because he campaigns in person whereas
joe biden has no ground game he thinks
that
all of his ad should be spent on cable
news when donald trump speaks directly
to people
he does better and so this is why i
think this example of kristen welker is
so important
because you can see the actual
interaction that takes place
when donald trump is answering the
question and then we will show you
how she surmised him addressing the
question after
very yang and yang you know what i'm
talking about yeah here's the first one
i don't know do i see him rattled it's
uh unfortunate that this is
a world but the world's always been
a dangerous place now listen cool calm
and collected
these are not usually objectives you
would use to describe donald trump no
that just happens to be one of them
when asked about this exchange this is
how she told her partners in media the
president responded
i asked the president if he was rattled
by all of this he said of course but he
also expressed his gratitude
he said none of that no
no no that's the exact opposite of what
he said
when people say oh journalism is
important and jake tapper going out
there virtually yeah twitter she's one
of the finest among us
well yeah cause you're all equally
pieces of [ __ ]
sure she's the mushroom growing in the
turd pile
yeah where's the cnn fact checker coming
on and fact-checking themselves because
where does it stop it's like hey are you
a child rapist
no well when i asked if he was a child
rapist he said uh it's what i live for
john back to you
hope to see joe biden at the next
meeting were you rattled do i seem
rattled listen it's unfortunate followed
by
he said of course so wow
i mean all she has to do is be just
slightly less uh
attacking than savannah guthrie and
she's already gonna do a
better job i mean here look all they got
to do is do the stephanopoulos right
which
you know the one time he pushed back and
he was like but joe what about fracking
no you don't want to answer that
okay okay yeah i'm sorry yeah my
apologies
she's gonna be able to mute the
microphone she's gonna be uh senator uh
president trump who she was gonna say
senator that's joe biden he's uh senator
say president trump uh are you a child
rapist listen i
he said yeah he said yes yes
it's oh my world right here folks
you know what we're going to use we're
going to feed this to our friends at
buzzfeedslate and nbc.com and abc and
then
use that as a source for why he's a
child rapist
yeah every time meanwhile on the stage
you have a man who actually
sniffs children not a rapist but it's
weird enough it's very weird
for me it's a red flag can you just
picture this if you were just sitting at
the mall
or at a park yeah i don't know you're
waiting on your uh you're waiting on
your wife going into talbots
and uh you're sitting there and you got
a kid maybe he's got an ice cream cone
and just some guy just shimmy's up next
to him like the lady in the park bench
and force gump and just
your son yeah they'd lock me away
exactly they'd lock me away as a parent
how would you respond if you're out
there saying that this is no big deal as
a parent how would you respond would you
be like oh good
somebody's sniffing you you must be
clean how do you think the police would
respond to the report
like okay so we see lacerations on the
forehead
you choked him on and you said that you
did this because he was
he was your son he was sniffing him
they would go sir that's true sir we're
not killing
yeah i mean it's it's crazy it's great
and
it's not just one example right for the
report right right
it's crazy it's like the hunter buying
laptop right it's not there's no denials
it's just
oh yeah next topic yeah they're trying
to make me look bad
and that'll get us to another one here a
question that he answered from her but
with biden it's just uh hey
can you deny the authenticity or yeah
you would ask that
yeah i am
you're correct that was the question i
just asked
hold on i got a dexter's lab scratch and
sniff with my name on it i have four
pages of dede
um just make sure i'm not on a zoom
call good lord so here's another one
um welker by the way deleted her
entire twitter account before the debate
oh i wonder why yeah that's just
something like kevin roose over there
when he
called new york times yeah where he was
asking his policies to delete all his
tweets because he makes his living off
of digging up old tweets
he knows the game so this is how
confident she is in her standing kristen
welker she
right there you see that example and she
deleted all so her twitter was dead to
begin with
now another thing you may not know she
comes from bruce willis
she comes from a family of big democrats
democrat
she actually spent her christmas in the
white house
that's a that's a communist eloise story
[Laughter]
eloise left her penthouse for the white
house yeah and then she was sniffed by
the vice president
oh and then she ran away there we go
spoilers uh we have more to get to by
the way hit the notification bell if
you're subscribed because uh
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
of course the notifications let you know
when we do the show
weekday mornings at 10 a.m eastern and
tomorrow is the debate stream
so excited here's another one you may
not know uh again this is only important
because
and this isn't a character assassination
it's uh
it's journalistic integrity
assassination
yeah and i'll claim it um
in 2016 she got busted for a lot of
people don't know this the hot mic
incident where she was actually
there was uh hillary clinton had a
campaign spokesperson i don't know if
what's in between a spokesperson
representative and spock's nothing
okay i think fox is just short spock's a
short bomb yes
why they just want to keep us confused
they want to keep us confused like
spokesperson representatives spocks
uh are you rattled do i look rattled he
was rattled i don't know what to believe
anymore it's almost like they're lying
on purpose
look at those dirty spots over there wow
an
interesting story about spock's
[Laughter]
cruise no not too fond now
it was a star trek cruise
she was caught in a on a hot mic trying
to tip off
a hillary clinton representative um and
this is i believe when her
and bernie were locked into close race
and it's so uncomfortable you wouldn't
believe it if i wrote this in an article
at loudout's credit.com so
let's go to the tape go right to kristen
welker kristen go ahead
he's okay okay and i'm gonna ask you
about flynn
kristen go ahead you're live christian
police kristen welker in the spin room i
believe
she has the clinton communications
director with her go ahead kristen okay
thank you
i think this is his last question um
hey ari i'm here with communications
director jen paul mary for the clinton
campaign
i mean at least at least donna brazile
had the courtesy of doing it by email
so that we couldn't hear the tone of
voice
just think about this they're tipping
off you don't think they're tipping off
biden to the questions right now please
how can you trust this how can you trust
this debate being fair
um and here's another one that i think
is most telling
uh well not not most telling because of
her because she's terrible
but because of donald trump's answer and
i think it's interesting to contrast
that with an answer
of our favorite sniffer in chief today
with his scandal so let's go to kristen
welker of course asking donald trump
about completely unfounded russia
allegations and his response
mr president yes or no have you
or are you now have you ever worked for
russia i never worked for russia
and you know that answer better than
anybody i never worked for russia
not only did i never work for russia i
think it's a disgrace
that you even asked that question
because it's a whole big fat hoax
that's like a definitive answer very
definitive now granted when she went on
anderson cooper she said i asked him if
he had worked for russia
and he said that uh that's where he made
a majority of his income
uh back to you anderson he said yes
here to talk about this is jeffrey tube
and jeffrey whitman
oh no jeffrey you're live put a sticky
note
on your camera that was good enough for
joe lewis right there i think we have
the joe lewis camera
for people who can't uh no do nothing so
let's
contrast that donald trump have you ever
worked for russia
no absolutely not i've never worked for
russia
and you should be ashamed for even
asking that question because you know
it's a hoax
compare that with biden every single
time he's been asked he goes uh i'm not
gonna answer and you would ask that kind
of question fat
right he just completely avoids it the
easiest thing to do
would be deny the authenticity of the
emails which by the way
biden hasn't done no but cnn has done
abc nbc cbs young turks slate vox they
all just say this is so ridiculous it's
not true
well hold on a second unlike the peeing
russian prostitutes
unlike the story we had of donald trump
calling troops losers and suckers what
do we have
we have the laptop we have the pictures
already that are irrefutable proof that
at least he was doing this we have the
emails
um we have the lawyer's email requesting
the laptop back
and now we have what appears to be an
authentic verified
proof of purchase with hunter biden's
signature i don't know how much
more you need that's a lot well there's
there's one way that we can make the
media talk about this and that's if
trump brings it up at the debate
right which would be awesome the problem
with that though is it won't do
well with the audience right oh shipping
better on the economy which won't be
discussed or gun control which won't be
discussed the media will never ask any
questions so this is the problem donald
trump has to do the job of the media
right now
that they won't do this is some and it's
not about hunter biden
it's about joe biden it's about him
being the big guy which has also been
confirmed from third party producer
saying the big guy getting a cut
is joe biden it's about the leverage
that foreign entities could have on joe
biden it's not about hunter biden
it's about someone else having access to
this kind of information
we know that that's been leveraged
against politicians you can see it with
sex scandals you can see it with anthony
weiner for crying out loud
you don't think that someone had jeffrey
toobin by the short hairs until he
screwed up and did it himself i can't
tell you
he had to do the bidding for someone who
was like it would be a shame if i reveal
this footage of you furiously
masturbating in your office wouldn't
like well i didn't know anyone watching
it was a zoom call
tubin it was on your schedule i muted it
i muted
[Laughter]
by the way you know who says this is not
a russian hoax the fbi do you know who
else also said this
john ratcliffe the guy who's the head
over there yeah yeah head of
intelligence but
listen because the fbi says it doesn't
mean enough because they've been trying
to go after trump for a long time
they've had access to these contents the
laptop for a long time
haven't done anything i think that makes
it more more believable because
obviously they would be going for biden
they'd say no it's i don't know maybe it
is maybe it's not right
but they've said no it is absolutely
remarkable and this lady well i
shouldn't say remarkable this lady's
going to be moderating the debate do you
think that it's going to be safe do you
think that it's going to be fair
because everyone knows that the gaps are
closing right now and these states
are within the margin of error and uh
one thing to i wanted to
build half asian bill wasn't here
yesterday but people try to give me
black where i was saying i cannot stand
jerry lewis well don't speak of the dead
and i was saying well what about
speaking of the guy who called a kid a
[ __ ]
on air on a telethon with muscular
dystrophy and people are saying you're
just looking for an excuse to say no no
i did the impression yesterday where he
said hey how about you didn't know your
son would be a [ __ ]
dad and i had it almost right we had to
dig into the archives
here is the clip of jerry lewis being an
unfunny awful person
oh your family has come to see you
you remember bart your older son
jesse the illiterate [ __ ]
arguably that was worse than the
impression it was yeah yeah it really is
why did it get illiterate on top of it i
know
you know that's why that's why now in in
order to cancel jerry lewis progressives
are now in favor of muscular dystrophy
oh they're like you know an enemy of my
enemy is my friend
yeah so and they don't know what to do
with them
what the quandary aids depends on
how much greg louganis is diving that
day
uh we have a lot so i want to know your
opinions on this then we're going to get
to joe biden's unbelievably radical gun
control that no one has talked about and
then we're going to go exclusively to
mud club with building your legal
questions
uh but first thank you so much to our
wonderful sponsor expressvpn here you go
our world is increasingly ruled by
technology
information moves faster than the speed
of light
but how do you know that you and your
personal information
are safe that's why you should protect
yourself with the latest in cyber
security technology
a sticky note are you worried that it
might leave you open to hackers spies
geo blocks ip detection ad targeting
nsa habit tracking traffic logs
third-party microphone access and theft
of your personal data
we've got you covered with a sticky note
and if you're concerned about all that
other stuff
there's always expressvpn
now see here's the thing when we wrote
that commercial um it was
far more funny than sirius which now
actually sticking out is relevant
because
you go to expressvpn.com you get three
months free on your
uh first year subscription and again
they're the only uh vpn that you see
advertised on these podcasts out there
that
have not had any kind of a security
breach that i know of oh that's good
it's expressvpn.com
crowder it's a good just protect your
data if you're online because people
have access to
all of it however yeah and we use it we
used it with some of the youtube
algorithms
obviously yeah we'll be talking about
big tech later we'll be talking about
big tech labor we all use expressvpn
but it won't protect you that's where
this listen a multi-pronged approach
yes like you should have a dog prepared
in that right joe lewis you should have
a dog
as well as a firearm and an alarm system
at your house to protect yourself so you
should use expressvpn
but a sticky note particularly if you
plan on masturbating on work zoom calls
and let me explain yeah because
expressvpn will not help you from that
and this is the thing i know people say
well what's the protection here well
there's not much but this is where the
concept of scale
comes in right over there like
perspective
yeah a little bit perspective under
and jerk so let me show you exactly how
this works tubing in the future if you
get on a zoom call look you can't
obviously this doesn't work right here
i mean it's kind of too late on this one
but if you have a sticky note sticky
note is small
but now the sticky note look right there
i get it up close that's the scale still
the same size
can you guys see anything what are you
doing steven this is a psa
this is great it is filthy oh
gerald put your pants back oh my god no
no
sanitizer or something so the point is
for most of you who are non-degenerates
expressvpn.com crowder is good enough if
you're jeffrey tubin i would also invest
in sticky notes and some kind of stack
some kind of a lacquer so
the sticky notes don't think i'm too
sticky we sent him some did we yeah just
a little just self-address well you know
what
they're disposable in his case he's
going to need a whole box
we also sent him tissues too so just is
there any more embarrassing way for your
career to end
hey he's taking time but not having fun
sniffing a child
well that's true charges are pressed
from a child who's like he
sniffed me yeah and he has to go sit
down in court and say yes i sniffed this
child despite the child saying this is
an unwanted
advance right that would probably be
more in joe biden's case it's like no i
didn't uh sir we have
video of multiple video in fact there
are more
victims now than we knew in the
beginning it's not going to be as funny
as when we find the security footage
from the guy the computer repair shop
and it turns out it was kamala who
dropped off the laptop
she's like me and snoop dogg
here's a laptop she dropped it off to
lash out at biden because he wouldn't
stop sniffing her hair you never take a
black woman's hair
oh that's true and he kept interrupting
her even though she paused well she kept
it stephen
i'm not done stepping around stephen
okay your bit is annoying
that's true cheryl doesn't understand
it's like it doesn't work because then
people just
like it's one thing but then we just
want to hit you
gerald you're here to be the smart one
okay don't forget the
failing at all things i am the cute one
he's just my [ __ ] so
little olsen twins humor for you oh
there's a little bit of edge
where are they yeah are they locked in
are they like they're right
there they're billionaires they are
billionaires they own
everything they're wherever they want to
be um all right so uh it is time now
actually to move on to
um uh i can't believe that this hasn't
been i can believe
but this is something that should be
reported on far more
um it's time to shoot this with joe
biden
fire two blasts outside the house
you shoot them in the leg
okay so again that's not the worst
that's not the worst of it uh the worst
of it is his policy
on his website so go to joebiden.com is
it joebiden.com someone let me know if
it's gun safety if it's gun control and
then let me know and we'll find it uh
but you can go to his website and
someone will chime in later let me know
audio wait when you find it
um i was surprised when i read this
and half asian people you didn't know
about this i did so i said don't ask me
the question
i will tell you on air and i will read
directly from his website joe biden's
gun control
policies are far more radical than
people
feared barack obama's would be yeah a
lot of people don't understand this
uh did you find it there yeah joe
biden.com gun safety gun
yeah like shoot him in the leg yeah
think about this too the topics for the
debates we don't have the economy in
there we don't have gun control by the
way do you know
there have still been shootings that
have taken place across america it's not
like no one's been shot just look at the
chicago statistics
no news on it no no on mass shootings at
all as you go to election why because
it's the single most losing issue for
democrats particularly
in the rust belt in the midwest where
people are avid hunters in michigan
right my home state of michigan you you
did not need a permit when i lived there
you didn't need a permit at all to open
carry
only to conceal carry you go in you
purchase a firearm you can open carry
and a big reason for that is because you
have so many hunters
if they have to track a deer across the
freeway you don't want some soccer mom
no i can't
i can't i saw a gun i can't even like
okay well you know what maybe he should
put you in his meat freezer
oh i don't know if it's venison very
domination yeah
it's a fatty meat a little too gamey for
my taste
so the plan is so radical here is
something that surprised me and no one
here believed me when i told them and i
will read from it
joe biden his plan would and now you've
heard about the online loophole
yeah yeah i don't know what that is
that's not a real thing i've purchased
you helped purchase with my father
an old marlin lever action like kind of
an heirloom firearm from a gun broker
which is the biggest gun auction site
yep
and this was something where obviously
it couldn't be a surprise because
ultimately i had to have it shipped
from a dealer to a dealer i have to go
in and file paperwork so i don't know
what the online
loophole ever was but it doesn't matter
because they're not even arguing that
anymore
joe biden will ban any and all
online firearm ammunition or accessory
sales
meaning under a joe biden administration
according to his own website
you can't buy a grip a trigger spring
a holster depending on how you define
accessories let me read right here
biden's plan would
quote from his website end the online
sale of firearms and ammunition
biden will enact legislation to prohibit
all
online sales of firearms ammunition
kits and gun parts wow did you know that
i didn't and when you said i literally
didn't believe you and i was like no
there's no there's
this is such a ridiculous proposition
particularly if you're trying to get
these states that are currently the
swing states right particularly also by
the way if you're trying to look at
making something safer where you can
regulate it
online sales there's a record exactly
there's a record there's no way to buy
it out of the back of a trunk
right again people who sell their
firearms on website the main websites
now if you can go on the dark web and
commit a crime that's not a loophole
you're a criminal it's a crime i don't
think that there's a blood slash
[ __ ] initiation loophole you had to
steal a gran torino and shoot an 85 year
old is that a loophole you're just a
felon
so so some people don't know that i
actually didn't i hadn't really shot any
firearms before until college and in
college i worked
at an online seller of these types of
products midway usa it's an excellent
company learned about them that's when i
got into competitive shooting
and that kind of thing amazing folks
they worked throughout the industry but
one of the things that i always asked
about them because i was new to
the gun culture and to the industry was
why
like who who are the kinds of people
that are buying these things you know
what it is it's
people in places where they don't have
access to be able to get self-defense
ammunition yeah the only thing they can
get at the walmart are hunting rounds
but they're they didn't buy the gun for
hunting in fact they don't even like
hunting
they're doing it to protect their
families right there are a lot of people
who are trying to you know
often out in areas where the police
response time is a mere four days
exactly
you know what else is a gun accessory a
gun lock a gun safe right
you know oh you want to make sure you're
cleaning your gun you want to make sure
that you're keeping it safe
all of those things would fall under
that now maybe he's going to come and go
oh
i didn't mean those kinds of accessories
but that's the kind of lack of clarity
but at the high end he's
clearly wanting to make sure that we're
going to limit the access to a thing
that enables us to exercise our second
memory let me ask this gin
who knew this before i i decided last
night we're going to talk about this now
anyone here show of hands know that
biden will end
all online sales of guns ammo
parts kits accessories a little frilly
things
did anyone here know this until i just
told you it's on his website ban all
outlining sales
i thought it was an exaggeration when
you started talking about it i really
did it there's no way that this could be
somebody's policy
it is did you know quarterback here no
did you know audio awaits not free
we all know about the assault weapons
ban right what he wants to bring back
and
define assault weapon and anything over
10 rounds in a magazine
so he wants to do all that too but these
are the things that are incredibly
radical
here's another one because since you
just talked about safes uh he wants to
be
uh able to charge adults for minors
accessing guns now i know what you're
saying it's like if an adult
and it's already a crime if an adult
gives a miner a firearm that they don't
they don't have the legal authority to
possess that's a crime sure
that's not what the law is let me again
read from the website
hold adults accountable for giving
minors access to firearms
biden supports legislation holding
adults criminally and
civilly liable for directly or
negligently giving a minor access to a
firearm regardless of whether the miner
actually gains possession of the firearm
what
so like if a gun's up on a shelf in the
house can you tell me how that reads
that's how it reads to me like if you
don't have in other words you could be
criminally and civilly liable if you
have a nightstand
gun safe that if you have a nightstand
gun that isn't in a safe even if the kid
never accesses it never uses it doesn't
know that it's there because it says
very clearly
holding adults criminally and civilly
liable for directly or
negligently giving a minor access to a
firearm
whether the miner or not actually gains
possession of the firearm can you
explain that legally to i'm a little
a little murky i mean it's it's a direct
attack on anyone who has a firearm
if it's in the house and not locked down
with the nuclear codes it's a crime so
so get this let's say your master
bedroom's on the second floor of your
house
your nephew comes over you're playing in
the front yard your sister and nephew go
in and go to the bathroom on the first
floor
they're in the house the gun is on the
second floor
it may be not even locked right maybe
it's behind the bed stand or up on a
shelf or something like that
you're single you don't have kids the
kid's not even on the floor not even in
the same room nowhere near the gun
that might possibly fall under it and
here's the point maybe after four years
of litigation and two years of appeals
you'll win that case
but you're bankrupt you've already lost
it and the reason is because biden has
created a law
that allows people to sue you for
something that is currently not even
being asked for
and we've seen this all the time now
we've seen neighbors turning on
neighbors brother against brother
you know something about end times i
believe the bible says something about
this somewhere in the back something in
there
you can have a neighbor who doesn't like
oh i know that family has guns over
there yeah and then they go yeah yeah go
over there on a play date and then they
bust
and go hey hey police officers my
neighbor has kids there and i think
there are guns that aren't locked in
that exact scenario and guess what
all of a sudden the bain gestapo come in
and say oh well listen we're gonna have
to write you up just like they do now
uh if you happen to have a business in
new york where you're doing takeout only
but your front door is open we'll talk
about that tomorrow
the problem with authoritarianism isn't
just that this is that these are
rules are coming from the top it's the
people who will enforce it
yeah and the people who will enforce
trying to use the system to take away
your rights and the second amendment is
a huge one
because it's number two number one
freedom of speech religion
assembly uh protest all of those but you
know the left doesn't care about those
either so long as transgenders can take
a [ __ ] in the right target bathroom
so here's another one hate cri the hate
crime loophole yeah this is something
you know
that is incredibly disturbing because
people go oh what's uh you can commit
hate crimes right now yeah that's a
loophole
no no no no so we've gone through
banning all online sales right banning
having firearms and kids in a house
period effectively making it illegal and
now he says
on his website he'll close the hate
crime loophole by quote bring us up to
cute maddie
legislation prohibiting an individual
who has been convicted of a misdemeanor
hate crime
or received an enhanced sentence for a
misdemeanor because of hate
or bias in its commission from
purchasing or possessing
a firearm this is what's important
what's a misdemeanor hate crime we need
to define this right
you're going out there and you're
shooting up a black church no that's
actually a felony
and the primary issue with that is not
so much that you hate people
it's that you tried to kill people yes
yes that's true um
already really bad what do you have to
say to be charged with a misdemeanor
hate crime
just say naughty words no are you
exaggerating no we have cases of this
we've talked about it before
uh students at the university of
connecticut remember they were playing a
game where they yelled increasingly
offensive words back and forth
we used to play this in high school
people it was the penis game when i was
right yeah remember that we say penises
you know you have to go out of class
apparently they were playing a game
where it's like saying
racial slurs now irresponsible sure yeah
but they're 13. i know you think they're
responsible enough to smoke a joint and
change their sex but i don't think
that's necessarily responsible yeah
to be held accountable because their
synapses haven't formed it doesn't mean
they're racist it means they play stupid
games well guess what
these kids were charged with a
misdemeanor hate crime for playing a
game
then we also have uh people recently
who've been charged with misdemeanor
hate crimes
simply when black lives matter
protesters attack their vehicle and they
continue
driving so this is this comes down to
your understanding of the second
amendment and fundamental rights do you
forego
your rights because you said a bad word
do you forfeit your rights now i think
you forfeit your rights when you rape
somebody and murder somebody i think you
forfeit certain rights because
you decided to infringe on other
people's rights but if you defend
yourself if you're driving down a street
and someone throws himself on your car
like the lady in happy gilmore get me
out of here you keep driving should
you lose your right to protect your wife
and kids well this is the policy from
joe biden
hate crime that explain to people that
hate crime misdemeanors that is such a
low bar well it's all it's already a low
bar but it's already a ridiculous bar
i mean the simple fact that we're
dehumanizing certain types of crime
because it wasn't
hate motivated because by giving it
additional factor an increasing factor
on something that is
hate motivated whether it's a
misdemeanor or a felony a misdemeanor
part's a whole different bad part
but the underlying concept of a hate
crime is that there are worse
murders than regular murder right right
and it's not just premeditated
but premeditated hate murder should be
even worse we kill you twice we kill
your kids i don't know what the answer
is
but but it's it's it doesn't make any
sense and it further divides
america it further divides ourselves you
know why because it's all it's also not
multifaceted i talked about this
yesterday
uh sure people do kill based on hatred
but it's not just skin and it's not just
gender you have far more people millions
of people who've been killed
based on hatred of their ideology that's
what you see
that's what you see in soviet russia and
guess what the people who were being
hate
killed looked a lot like the people who
were hate killing them it's not a race
thing they said oh you're a dissident
oh you're speaking out against the
government we hate your ideas and we
kill you it'd be really hard to probably
tell the difference sorry i have asian
bill from the guy
in the tank running over the guy in
tiananmen square from the guy in
tiananmen square if you were to line
them up in a police lineup and they
would say who touched you
who sniffed you like uh oh wait it's joe
biden yeah it's not either of the asians
but i put them right there i didn't know
they were both the same height same eye
color same hair
so do you think that they even know they
have this on their website anymore like
they've denied stuff being on their
website before like
stuff and it's like oh crap it's still
there do you think that this was like
out there before the black lives matter
protest why this should be a question of
the debate
hey joe biden uh you're running uh right
now for president united states
and important states are the uh
midwestern states where hunting is
actually more common than anywhere else
in the country particularly states like
wisconsin michigan and pennsylvania
your website says that you would ban all
firearm
sales accessories ammunition kits parts
online as well as criminalizing people
owning guns with children present if
they aren't locked up in a safe
uh what do you think that will what kind
of an effect do you think that will have
in uh your election uh
uh likelihood in the swing states huh
listen that's right up your alley asking
that kind of a question
yes it is because i'm a fair moderator
what who how is he here
so unfair to quote me to me okay
he quotes me to me so angry just because
i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] like
it's like she's afraid of me and can't
you see
just because i want to sniff a toddler
so
[Laughter]
[Applause]
bathroom
if someone if someone had a delorean and
travel to the future
system of it down is why the armenian
genocide happened whoa
it shouldn't have i'm not condoning it
no of course i'm not denying it but if
they're looking
for denying it like turks i think it's
horrible right but i'm saying because i
think
they're like why would that why would
you ever do that it all it seemed sort
of out of the blue
but if someone could travel to the
future and they saw they saw that they
were like
can't let this happen would you kill
baby hitler
would you end baby system of a down in
the garage
that's horrible they missed him i missed
just someone runs up and steals their
guitar
just that that's it it's like you just
can't just keep coming back
that's my guitar he's running away down
the street
see surge doesn't even play the guitar
between
maple and oak ridge street and orchard
[Applause]
all right yeah move on and he looks like
what's his name the guy
uh the guy yeah it's like someone said
hey you know what's marketable a guy who
sings like crap
and looks like the swashbuckler from
princess bride
so you can't say that you couldn't say
stuff like this if biden was president
because that would be a misdemeanor hate
crime
right yeah yeah hate crimes scratching
so uh here's another thing a lot of
people have talked about the bannon
assault weapons and we've done this
before we've talked about it the ins and
outs it's a
it's a fake thing right the idea of
assault weapons there's a difference
between an assault weapon and an assault
rifle
which is something that has burst fire
in the military so assault weapon is a
made-up term look
this is legal this is illegal it's just
a pistol grip that's all that changes it
it's what kind of aesthetics it's a it's
a backdoor gun grab and it was wildly
unpopular
now uh biden is very open about the fact
that he would ban all
undefined assault weapons here you go so
to to gun owners out there who
say well obama administration means
they're going to come for my guns
bingo you're right if you have an
assault well the fact of the matter is
they should be illegal
period to be clear he thought he was
actually playing bingo
oh bingo got it right here bingo
sorry we're still doing the interview
huh are we playing seven up
huh thumb up okay uh was it uh
stanfordopolis he's not here sir okay
you guys play seven up as a kid no yeah
yeah i don't know if that was a canadian
thing so uh there's him saying he's
going to ban all assault
and he didn't equivocate no he didn't
know it's very clear and he mentioned
the buy-back he talks about the buy-back
program quite a bit too it says it talks
about it on his website a gun buyback
now here's what's so concerning we've
talked about
australia and the gun buyback that was a
mandatory buyback
and considering how specific joe biden
is on banning
all firearm sales and ammunitions online
and making you criminally liable and
civilly liable even if there is
actually no child who reaches a firearm
in your house whatsoever
the vagueness here is concerning because
it just mentions buyback well all
examples we have of buybacks have
by and large been mandatory so here is
well would it be mandatory i don't know
because it doesn't specify
but he did say that his guns gunzar was
going to be francis o'rourke
who you may know him how are you going
to take away weapons
from people who do not want to give them
up and you don't know where they are
if someone does not turn in an ar-15 or
an ak-47 one of these
weapons of war or brings out in public
and and brandishes it
in an attempt to intimidate as we saw
when we were at kent state uh recently
then that weapon will be taken from them
uh if they persist there will be other
consequences
this guy you're going to take care of
the gun problem with me
you're going to be the one who leads
this effort son of a [ __ ]
there it is yeah so yeah saying it's
going to be a mandatory buyback between
kickflips
and then joe biden saying he's going to
be my gunzar and his website says
there's going to be a buyback so banning
all
online sales whatsoever of firearms
ammunition accessories
making you criminally civilly liable for
having a firearm in the house if a child
happens to be present at any point even
if they don't actually gain possession
of the firearm
assault weapons ban which isn't defined
and then a buyback which we don't know
whether it's mandatory but he will
appoint beto o'rourke
as gunzar who said that he will kick
down your door and take away your ar-15
said so adamantly hell yes so i wonder
why
we're per capita we have some of the
most gun owners in the country like
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania
the media has not questioned joseph
biden at all
about his own firearm policies on his
own website you tell me what you think
that is this has been shooting the sh
with biden
fired two blasts outside the house
you shoot him in a leg
and what however the left never gets it
right like ar-14s and it was uh chenk
weaker said like ar 13.
they're just going down it's gonna keep
going if it's 13. they're eventually
going to get it right because they'll
get to the ar-10 which is fine that's a
whole different platform but
was the ar-10 the shotgun no that's the
308 it's like the larger caliber
oh okay but this isn't an ar-12 or ar-13
there's a shotgun i mean there is a
shotgun version but
the ar the ar platform is just a
platform you can put any i mean you
could shoot cotton candy out of it it's
just a
cool i know people have nine millimeter
ar-15s they have 22 ar-15 so they can
practice their shooting farmer which
by the way people out there who are on
youtube right now send in your legal
questions we will be talking about the
section is it bill 230
we're talking about section 230 which is
already in law the communications
decency act we're going to talk about
the new doj proposals to
modify section 230 a recent opinion from
clarence thomas about 230
that should up end the law give him
everything all the things and the doj
suit
and the doj suit not a robe would you
refuse to wear
two things one they conflate ar-15s with
ak-47 every single time
they say that these two things are one
and the same right right they always use
that because the ak-47 of course looks
scary
right and it is an automatic weapon it
actually is a weapon of war that they
use from
right you're wrong it can be
automatically look the ak-47 is a
platform
a platform can make it automatic or
something well
a second there no this is important
because you're crossing wires and
there's a difference between for example
an m16 which is used in the military
which automatically has
automatic and burst fire capabilities
right and ar-15
what defines that differently is that
it's typically available for civilian
use where it only has a semi-automatic
function right
that terminology isn't as clear with
ak-47 correct because they can come in
either way
right i want to hear more about this
cotton candy gun
please i know your wife called you have
the diabetes no no no
do you and also so this is a question
for you do you think that
trump is going to bring this out because
you're right it's not just the swing
states though it's everybody who's been
affected by riots and the blm protests
like their
gun guns are off the table for a decade
for democrats but this is still on his
website
yeah i think he just doesn't know it's
there do you think he's waiting donald
trump needs to focus on the biggest
winning issues which is the economy
by and large you know in the
working-class coalition but uh i i
i would think this could be more helpful
to donald trump especially with the
swing states than the hunter biden thing
because the hundred divided thing you're
just gonna have to
hope that the media does its job and do
that behind the scenes i don't think the
debate
the debate is not you don't have enough
time to explain
uh all of to connect all the dots for
people and it's so
incredible to believe that i think would
be a hard sell
no one's gonna if donald trump goes up
there like someone on cable news saying
like well you know it's very concerning
that actually
uh the hunter biden's laptop was dropped
off
himself we have a signature and his
lawyer asking for it back in which he's
uh having sex with prostitutes on camera
while smoking crack
and selling his father's services
referring to him as big guy he's like
really that sounds sinister if donald
trump said listen the laptop
shows biden sun smoking crack banging
hookers
people were like oh it's not true yeah
right exactly
even though it's all true yeah and it's
all true
at some point it's just picking on
hunter biden in a lot of other people's
minds right if you're
if you're for joe biden this is just
them trying to tar and feather a kid and
he's not a kid he's a 50 year old man
he's a 50 year old man who's never
gotten it right and his father is
involved
there's already enough his father lights
and he had no idea well he's already we
know that he's met with some of these
people were there business dealings
we don't know now again the media should
be doing their job that is their job
and think of the arrogance this is what
bothers me most the arrogance of jeffrey
tubin thinking that ah you know
who what is it if i if i just choked the
chicken on a skype zoom call
who among us the arrogance there is he
thinks well it's okay because i'm
liberal so it's fine
i'm the right kind of person the
arrogance of joe biden is i'll just hide
out
and the media won't ask me when they ask
me i won't answer and they won't press
me on it
what a luxury to have and that shows you
we'll talk about it more next week the
coalition this is something people need
to understand when bernie bros like get
big money out of politics it's always
funny young turks like get big money out
of politics they have a pack
for it they have an organization for it
there is no candidate i think
who is is emblematic more emblematic of
big money than joe biden let's look at
those coalitions really quickly okay
wall street backs joe biden people say
donald trump loves wall street no donald
trump wants people's 401ks to do well
donald trump is wealthy enough that he
didn't have to be beholden to wall
street
listen you may hate billionaires i
understand you may hate rich people but
guess what rich people are a lot more
expensive to buy
yes that's important to note the kind of
people who could buy hunter biden or joe
biden they can't buy donald trump
because that's beer money it's the kind
of money that
it's the equivalent to him finding 500
000
in his coat it doesn't matter like you
the 20 in your old khakis
doesn't matter to him for and for
hitting billionaires so much biden sure
has taken a lot of money from them yes
that's the coalition so the biden
coalition is what
banks right it's wall street and all the
big banks big media
all of big tech big hollywood what's the
donald trump they talk about big money
what's his coalition
it's blue blue collar working class
voters who you make fun of as
white and uneducated well they don't
maybe they don't have a master's degree
but a lot of them have gone to trade
schools
so as we have blue collar workers small
business owners
law enforcement military and ironically
enough
here this election most unions that's
the coalition they're not the union
heads by the way
that's still part of the big money for
biden but the union members are breaking
overwhelmingly for donald trump so you
have big banks big tech
uh uh big media big hollywood versus
everyday working class americans so take
that in context imagine if donald trump
had any of that big money that joe biden
has
and then imagine if we had a fair
unbiased media this election would not
even be close and it still is close
so when someone when people say that you
know it's curtains no no it's anyone's
game at this point and i am amazed that
this one-man wrecking ball
is able to be as effective as he is
despite his flaws okay listen we love
you
we hear you for those who are mug club
members we're going to be taking your
legal questions in chat
talking about big tech youtube we don't
really want you to hear this
conversation in our strategizing so piss
off